[موسيقى]
تاجر الماضي يختلف عن تاجر الحاضر وقد
يكون الاختلاف جوهري ما هو بسيط جوهري
يعني يجينا عشره في اليوم كلهم يصورون
وواحد منهم يشتري له غرض معي
[موسيقى]
يا عيال مثلا يقول اضمن لك ميت واضمن لك
مره الجبل هذا
في الصفره اخوك كنت في البر وتجي وتناظر
سبحان الله الجبال اللي زي كذا اللي
يلموارات من هنا زي بعض كاوهم يمشون قال
وينك ميت هذا ولا هذا ولا هذا قال الثاني
اضمن لي بسكويت انه هذا واضمن لك مراتب
[موسيقى]
اسم عبد الرحمن بن عبد الله بن ابراهيم
مواليد ومن البدايه من قبل 44 سنه عام
1400 بادن احب الشيء القديم والترايب
يعتبر من اول المحلات الى قال لك اتذكر
فيه كل شيء قطع غيار اكل شرب علاج ادوات
ما اواني دكان يشمل كل شيء يباع
فلذلك انا بنبقيه يعني حفاظا على بقايا
النموذج الذكار القديم اللي من سبعين
وثمانين سنه
[موسيقى]
او يعني ننظر نظره ربحيه كان ساكنه من
زمان يعني زبائنة معروفين وقلب
[موسيقى]
كان زبائن الباديه والباديه ما عاد في
باديه الحين تقريبا يعني يجينا عشره في
اليوم كلهم يصورون واحد منهم يشتري له غرض
معين واللي يجي ويوقف هنا يحسب المحل قصير
يعني ما يدري ان المحل كبير هذه طريقتهم
في السابق كانت البضاعه واكثر البضاعه
تعلق
كثير من اللي يقول نظم نظم لو نظمت فقد
فقد قيمته التراثيه طريق القديمه هكذا
يا شاكر
منير لي يعني تقريبا
[موسيقى]
قلبي قلبي
حبي
وانا اشتاق لك بايديا
ابو عبد الرحمن
ابشر الله يجزاك خير ويطول عمرك
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
هذا السور القديم حق البلد
هذه احد البوابات هذا
علشان يفتح على البر من الاول شدني صراحه
نقوش الجميله يعني تلاحظ بعد التفاصيل
الدقيقه اللي في النقش اللي يشد العين من
جماعته
وهذه احد
الملكه هذا الجسم مرات تماما ما في خلط
ولا شيء طفيت انت الكاميرا
اذا خلصت علمني عشان اسولف عليكم
[موسيقى]
هذا اللي ياكل الخشب تشوف
هذا
وش تسوي بالباب
هذا جذوع النخل
[موسيقى]
حافظنا على اثاره حافظنا على تراثه حافظنا
على مبانيه حافظنا على الاغشاته محلاته
الجزء الاكبر في ماضي بلدنا حافظنا عليه
بقدر ما نستطيع طبعا الحب
حب جزء من حب الوطن هذا يعتبر جزء من الحب
والوطن
[موسيقى]
ولا يمكن ابو ست سنوات هذا بيت بنت خالي
اليوم هذا لو يجي سيل بكره او بكره تلقاه
[موسيقى]
نفتح بس محلي معفوس شوي بس ما في اضاءه
ما حضرته مهرجان التمور ليش
ليش ما جيتوني في محطه في محطه كامل
انت ويا ابو أي أنا وسامر
وتامر ما في خير يوم انه ما جابه
والله اني
حلبه مشققه على الفار والعب فينا الجن
الجرادي
التجاره واحده ولكن تاجر الماضي يختلف عن
تاجر الحاضر وقد يكون الاختلاف جوهري ما
هو بسيط جوهري كلش عن طريق الشبكه وكلش عن
طريق الحساب
ووكالات ولكن في القديم لا تكافل
الاجتماعي قوي
تكافل اجتماعي قوي
[موسيقى]
هذا محل من هذا محل الوالد واللي قبل شوي
محل عمي
هنا الوالد والله فيه في اشياء يعني
يستمتع بها ابوي كنت انا برضو استمتعت
يعني فيه مثلا مشط باقي شهر لحيته فيه
الميزان هذا لذكريات عندي ايام الوالد
اوريك اياها الان فيها اشياء لا فه ابوي
وحاطه عشان يضبط وزنيه الميزان الاشياء
الميزان الا جاب الميزان الا ود الميزان
الى حط الكيلو والكيلو وين وانا
لان هذا يعني اكثر من عمري الميزان هذا
هذا لفوق سبعين سنه الميزان عند الوالد
جعله في الجنه
بصماتي في اشياء صار جدال انا واياه اقول
هذا كذا وهو يقول لا كذا الله يغفر له
ويرحمه ويسكنه جناته
ابوي كان يقرا ويكتب بكتابه نجد القديمه
ما يعرف كتابته انا وهو فقط اخواني
والباقي اي واحد يجي من برا لا يمكن يطلع
السكاتب
انا انا افك حرف الوالد جالس في الجنه
ينصحنا عن
اللي عاد والسب
عن تطويل الثوب
عن الهرج في الناس
الثلاث اشياء هذه دائما نصب عينه في الجنه
ما دام الدنيا تطورت وظيف والناس اختلفت
ليش انت الحين تمسك بهذا الشيء اللي مالها
اول مال التاليه لابد ان يكون عندك
القناعه في قناعه
انا حاطه كنموذج يذكرون الجيل الجديد الان
يذكرون ماذا كان عليها ابائهم واجدادهم
[موسيقى]